and then it's the content which is the
most important thing you should do the
content with them and make sure it's all
amazing and they send you a script and
you should approve the script
a huge process but very very interesting
because we work with so many companies
and i always tell my employees you work
for 25
startups
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about storytelling meet regev ghoul
founder and ceo of narrative group
regev gore is a businessman entrepreneur
and pioneering the influencer and tech
marketing arena in 2018 he founded
narrative group which has since become
one of the largest influencer marketing
agencies in north america he is a
leading figure in the emerging tech
advertising industry and in 2021 was
recognized by forbes as one of the top
young entrepreneurs under 30.
welcome to 20 minute leaders yes thank
you so much thank you very very much for
hosting me in your beautiful beautiful
apartment
here in new york we have rafa here that
is joining us i think you may be able to
see a little bit of him he's looking at
me in a very endearing way and today
we're going to be talking about
influencer marketing yeah we're going to
be talking about the new generation of
marketing for b2c and b2b startups and
companies you know the world is changing
generation z is different we're looking
at influencers and we're looking at
micro influencers and you are a pioneer
in this field something that you've
realized uh quite a while ago and today
working with startups uh with some
pretty awesome announcements just
recently so tell me a little bit about
about yourself and how you see
marketing in this world
so in my opinion the best marketing the
best way to do marketing is by uh
getting reference and recommendations
and this is why i find influencer
marketing so effective
and if you saw in the past
so many brands that are not like not
tech related but like just beauty brands
and fashion brands or doing influencer
marketing those days you can see any
brand
from
classic b to b to c company you were
telling me
that marketing has changed and for you
the most effective marketing
is there is recommendations
yeah
i find recommendation is the most
effective thing ever imagine that
someone recommend you to do something
ins versus versus you see it on an ad or
any platform
it's uh
i think it is that that you buy trust
it's the most important thing that you
can do in marketing in 2022
right right now so let's let's let's go
one step back yeah if you think about
marketing what is in essence marketing
for you
basically it's everything there are so
many products that are the same
but if they win in marketing they win in
everything
this is why i'm a huge believer that
marketing is
probably the the most important role
in every company right um what's the
difference between uh between any sas
product to each other there is no much
difference the features are pretty much
the same but the marketing it's
everything the way you sell it out it's
everything and i think that uh that if
you recruit a bunch of people that has a
huge amount of followers to your team
uh you can win it
so i think that what you're touching on
is this trend now that we have
we have different verticals or different
spaces in which a lot of companies are
emerging that are that are that have
similar offerings obviously there's
there's nuance and there's differences
but but in general they're offering
similar products and the key
differentiator there it's the way that
they're selling it and how they're
convincing others to buy it right that's
the marketing yeah 100 that marketing
can be from everything first of all from
yeah from a good product from a better
product from a better offer
like financial financial wise money-wise
cost
but i think that eventually the way you
sell it that's the way for you
uh to actually move the needle between
same products okay beautiful so so we
agree that marketing is critical
this is where 21 2021 approaching 2022
this is it and we know also that that
the generation that is even younger than
us generation z they're very much
influenced for marketing right and so
traditionally most agencies i would
speak to
marketing agencies they would offer me
some ads they would offer me some
billboards tv commercials radio
commercials right but you're doing
something different
yeah
so
so we do ads
but it's not a typical ads it's
something that is it's way more
recommend related and then it makes it
almost no ad so we're trying i think
that the key is amazing content if you
work with the with the right influencers
on an amazing content that will perform
and and and this is what we do we
basically work between 100 to 200
influencers per month wow so we know
influencers almost in every vertical it
can be from uh diabetes because it's a
company that does something related to
diabetes and it can be uh
and it can be a tech influencers that
review tech and sus product so we work
with with almost 200 of them every month
and we know what works we already have
the experience to understand if this is
a real content person that can create
amazing content in a value price where
you can score your uh your goals
or if it's something that it's more ad
and then we don't touch it right
so
talk to me about influencers it's not
something that's trivial maybe you and i
we we think about in the day-to-day but
this is a new concept in the world
so i think it's an old concept that that
was having an upgrade nice
so
let's say 10 years ago if i'll tell you
to date with with like with the girl
versus uc or on any app or on the
newspaper or whatever you're going to
listen to my recommendation as your
friend as an expert whatever if i'm
going to recommend you to do something
you're going to probably uh do that way
before you saw it in any other place and
then you can support the idea from
different places so for example if you
do a campaign so to say yes you can do
pr
and you can do uh advertising on
television but you would like to support
it with the most experienced uh
tech influencer that actually review the
product and use it and he likes it that
he know the other products then you're
gonna listen to him right for example in
my case i'm a huge fan of
credit cards and flights and and and and
all of this field
some so i'm reading and i and i see
all of those youtubers that tells me
where to fly how to get more points up
to upgrade myself
it's i'm in this market
and then this guy is like a god for me
in terms of like yeah he'll tell me to
do x i'll probably gonna do that
incredible right but also so the content
that you would create
in an ad
is different when you're talking about
an influencers content versus you know a
15 second micro managed slot on the tv
right yes 100 100 so a good influencer
you don't need to do content with him he
will do that okay so what does that mean
how is it which also which also saves a
lot of production money
many companies likes to work with
creators i'm not going to call it
influencers but but but creators that
um they're going to produce everything
for them it's a one-man pro it's a
one-man production you don't need to buy
uh uh to pay for expensive actors and
sets and production days you just give
the brief to the influencer and he will
do whatever that's uh uh relevant for
his audience right
so but then how how does the com i mean
there's this there's a struggle here
because the company has one a specific
messaging that maybe the head of
marketing wants to put out that let's
say this new phone has a great battery
life yeah now the influencer maybe gets
that briefing and the influencer is
going to make a three-minute video maybe
they they'll talk about battery life and
maybe that's not going to be the focus
right because you're saying they have
more autonomy how do you manage that
struggle so
so
they need to do whatever it's on the
talking points okay
there is a talking points and we talk
about a lot about content before we do
any campaign especially with those very
uh uh uh
expensive slash
powerful influencers you wanna make that
make sure they're accurate with what the
company wants to say
you let them go free in terms of the
content but you give them kind of like a
like a very accurate uh
guidelines got and how do you then
manage
you know the
the authenticity
behind the influencer so imagine the
reason they did that you really enjoy
watching specific people with
recommendations because you you almost
believe that if they'll tell you that
their experience on ll is better than
united it's because they really do feel
that how do you then manage you know
when there's financials involved with
this so that's an amazing question and i
think that all the influencers should be
afraid
really yeah because
because many influencers are start are
starting to lose
their ability yeah
and
and this is why they take less
uh
less
projects right because they don't want
to recommend every single day about
something else
then no one is going to believe them and
then they worth nothing but there is a
solution for this right i mean there is
there must be a way for influencers who
genuinely like a product and they have a
great following to monetize on that
maybe there's an opportunity in the
market for that
yeah so
they're saying that they're gonna do uh
everything if only if they believe they
in the product
i'm not sure it's the right thing
i think that uh the professional
influencer that we work with they do
only project they care about the product
and they think it's a good product
we got so many reviews
like hey we don't want to work with this
type of company because it's x why is it
right
we work with
the best tech companies out there so
we don't get many no's but there are
there are influencers that it's not uh
uh it's not going well with their with
their brand so they right so they don't
take it we get we get few knows that for
every month interesting yeah and so what
does the actual process look like
from the moment that i as a startup am
interested in leveraging this creator
economy let's say or the influencer
marketing to the moment where i'm
actually getting something out there
what is happening there so it's
basically a very long and hard process
that we try to minimize it to the
shortest time
um
and you need to differentiate between a
b2c to a b2b product okay b2b product
it's way way more challenging
because you need to uh you need to
convince the decision maker which is not
a regular person at home
he is a head of sales in whatever
company you need to set to convince them
to use your product versus other product
he's way more judgmental than that than
other people right um so the selling
process of the influencer it's something
different but i also believe that elon
musk and adam single and all the rest of
those folks are influenced by someone
so in b2b case how do you find this
someone how do you find his podcast that
he's listening to and you integrate with
his podcast almost like inception yeah
yeah yeah it's very very hard how do you
and then when you when you do the
verticals if you want to target hr
managers right uh if your product is hey
bob that wants to target hr managers out
there in on the in the entire planet
where are all the hr managers what
facebook group that they're following on
like who is the mentor of hr award and
then we do the research so this is step
number one the research how do we find
those relevant places and the relevant
influence so as narrative group you
would get sort of the specs or the the
request
from the start and then you would go
into er into a diligence process trying
to figure out what is the best strategy
who is the best influencer and in what
sort of domain yeah 100
okay so it's all start from the from the
meeting with the clients but then from
the from from the research
after the research we approve those
people with the with the client with the
company to see if they like it or not if
they think it's relevant or not
obviously we give our recommendation
who to work with um
and then the the reach out part starts
many of them are not answering
so they're to answer us faster than
they're going to answer the brand since
we're already in this market for
uh uh for a good amount of time and we
give them so many uh works
so
and project
um
so and this is a i think the strength of
of an an agency this is the advantage of
being an agency or in you're in the
center of everything right and and from
the and then after the reach out the
negotiations start you need to negotiate
for the price because you want to find
for your clients the best prices out
there
uh the the
those big folks cost a lot of money per
uh per youtube or per video for any like
whatever deliverables that you want to
achieve right and then after negotiation
it's it's the it's the legal stuff you
need to do all the contracts
and then it's uh and then it's the
content which is the most important
thing you should do the content with him
and make sure it's all amazing and they
send you a script and you should approve
the script
a huge process but very very interesting
because we work with so many companies
and i always tell my employees you work
for
startups
companies because we're in the in the
core of the business which is marketing
so we know everything about the company
and you never get bored because you work
in so many verticals so it's fascinating
right and and so which part of this do
you enjoy most because you mentioned
that there's a wide range of pipeline
there's from this from working with the
startup to realize their needs to
strategizing for the right for the right
the right avenue for the influencer to
talking to the influencer to writing the
script and the talking points and
releasing so i obviously don't like the
legal stuff yeah
no one does yeah um
i like the negotiation a lot yeah yeah
i found myself
making
between 10 to 20 negotiation per day i'm
exhausted by the end of the day
but i love it uh i like to win it i'm
fine with losing it
it happens we do so many
deals so we lose where is the center of
the negotiation is it centered usually
around the money around the script
so yeah that's an amazing question they
care about many things and we care about
many things it can be about uh money
obviously this is number one like the
cost of the influencers because then you
understand if you're equi it's really
affect your acquisition
so so this is number one and then it's
the usage can i use those materials
after
the campaign
um we always wants to use those
materials everyone does and the
influencers know that so they there is a
price tag for that right and so you
negotiate this as well
but i think that i think this is the two
main things which is all about cost
and
and yeah there are so many small things
that i can't even explain you there
negotiation is a very very it's a very
hard
uh and but satisfying thing right i
think i think that makes that makes a
lot of sense and how long does this
process usually usually take
end to end
it really depends on the niche yeah but
if we start working today yeah we're
gonna start delivering in approximately
three weeks really yeah but then it's on
a on a weekly basis then we're in
business and
it's every time that we have a good
opportunity we pitch it okay i love it
and give me a few examples of narrative
narrative groups and perhaps some
projects just so that you know we can
become really concrete with with how you
with what type of work you're actually
doing
so the last engagement that we had so
far it's uh like two days ago
was with uh
with a huge influencer his name is uh mr
who is the boss the british guy super
talented
um
huge amounts of followers and not only
followers they listen to him they list
him yeah which this is influence people
for real yeah uh and this is why what
we're trying to uh to find when we look
for an influencers we care about the
niche and then we care about the the
numbers but we really care about his
engagement is he actually an influencer
uh we did it for an israeli company
called mine yep uh i guess you know the
people uh
was right here in this episode yeah a
super talented person that actually
understands a lot about
uh influencer marketing um a huge
startup in the data assistant area
um
so we did this campaign uh for them
uh
obviously i cannot say numbers we're
very very happy i mean anybody i went to
youtube myself i think right after you
posted on linkedin just to see what what
we're talking about here no i mean in
terms of views it's going to hit the two
million three million views it is insane
it's insane for an israeli company
israeli startup um
the review was amazing um
so yeah everyone is happy yeah yeah so
we do many of those right every week i
don't i don't publish it all the time
but but we do that a lot well i think
that you need to publish it a little bit
more because it's just fascinating to
see you know
how marketing changes but i want you to
take me back a little bit before your
marketing days and maybe it'll help me
understand a little bit better
while you're in marketing and and how
you're thinking about the influencer
economy in the crater economy going back
to your sort of childhood
yeah you know who is who is regen
so i had a very interesting uh childhood
i would say i guess many of many of us
does i don't think i'm special in
something uh a great family loving
family i grew up in jerusalem i was born
in jerusalem and grew up in jerusalem
and then we moved to maversett at ceo
and my my parents divorced when i was 12
i would say
um
and now all like since then i was in a
survival mode
where i need to
survive
to be the men in the house i don't think
i don't think like that now but this is
what i felt when i was a kid that i need
to take
ownership
and and i think this is what made me a
success like there is no other option
i'm starving
you know what i'm saying like i'm
starving to success i'm starving to make
it 100 yeah and and i love it i'm very
very happy that i didn't come from a
wealthy uh place
because then you're
you don't have the same drive in my
opinion that
that intrinsic motivation that
understanding that it's that the you
have the responsibility almost the
weight on your shoulder to to to succeed
because yes i wake up at 5am every day
because i'm super duper highly motivated
you know to make it i love it i love it
and if you're looking at the work that
you're doing today or the work that
you're that you're looking to do what
are where's the inspiration coming from
you know part of it i understand is this
intrinsic motivation of success of being
successful but where's the motivation
for the work that you're doing
so i have a huge motivation from only
from one source
i believe that uh that during your life
you need to give everything that you
have
in terms of money to donate your money
and to do good to people
so my dream is to be a philanthropist
not to uh to
not to to make money for myself yes to
myself as well i would like to live uh
happily
uh but i don't think that a person needs
so much
and
as long as you're a powerful person if
you're a powerful person it can be in
your school it can be in your class it
can be in your community and you can be
a huge philanthropist like a
multi-billionaire that that
help thousands of people right so that's
my dream
uh and this is why i do everything that
i do i love it like it's not a cliche
it's for real i think that you need to
finish with zero in your bank account
when you're dead
we'll hopefully leave a little bit for
the kids and then the the cycle can
continue as well teach them how to work
i think it's a you know it's not even
more oh yeah yeah thank you i really
want to thank you for the time brother
beautiful beautiful place thank you for
hosting me here thank you and
i i have to say
truthfully the pose that you posted with
with with mine and the influencer
marketing and thing the world is
changing the generations are changing
companies have to adapt you know what
we're seeing with the creator economy
all the way from gaming with twitch and
now we're looking at tech talk and macro
influencers and we're seeing the rise of
this greater economy and and it's really
awesome that that already a few years
ago you you were seeing this and that
you were the forefront and um and
working with with is also israeli
companies to get to these heights i
think it's just incredible so thank you
very very much thank you stay safe
you